good morning gamers today is a beautiful
day in Minecraft isn't that right
it's so much chicken so much awesome I'm
sorry alright if there wasn't so many of
you maybe I would have reconsidered but
there's way too many of you and
therefore you go to nangi ala okay
alright understand oh my god oh my god
spen
oh god how did this happen oh no stop it
stop it how did this happen
got the red show not the Redstone how
did this happen how oh god oh god oh god
oh god I got it spend do something what
is this sort I said oh there was lava
here oh my god it's burned from bottom
ground to up stop stop stop stop stop
stop stop stop the sacred pacts this
sacred text okay we can stop it we can
stop it oh my god it keeps spreading
get out okay then where is it burning oh
okay it would wood doesn't burn very
well oh god no that's a lie stop it stop
it stop stop stop stop stop stop stop
stop stop stop stop the stop please
what there I need what there why did I
not go for water right away oh god
there's a creeper in here sweating be
careful go away I don't have time dad
eat chicken eat chicken I need water I
need water I need water
oh no no oh please stop I know this
makes no sense I know it makes no sense
but I need the water
yes yes burn down there no I refuse I
refuse oh my god everything I guys think
it stopped I think it stopped we saved
we save the upper quarters we save the
upper quarters please donate to my
GoFundMe page I am it without the home
it almost burned down
Oh God this is worse than my house
getting robbed in real life I am so sad
you're my only love and hope
[Music]
okay so I've rebuilt the house that's
right it's been all day it's been all
day what did you do it what did you do
today oh you know I get off my property
oh you snake you're dead you're dead
you're still dead don't ruin my slime oh
my god how are they so many spawning
down here
these lights suck they don't give enough
light yeah spent all day rebuilding this
in wood again because big brain all
right I'm just gonna put these
everywhere sorry we don't discriminate
hey I was just about to say we don't
discriminate you're banned for life by
death productive day I would say yeah
[Music]
pretty good pretty good
not gonna like braid again it's a next
up on the list for me is to build a
proper elevator I want to have an
elevator go up there I don't know if you
guys remember I didn't where are you
guys 30 why I I did I did an elevator
for the meatball let's have a flash
don't you snake you do not oh my god I
all right I didn't want to do this but
just because that happened in bar we'll
have to pay a thousand times
eat [ __ ] think about that's what you get
thing my I get to keep said refilling
itself tips a pain of a thousand years
sing about a thousand years he will be
there forever anytime a creeper blow
something up anymore will pay this is a
message to all creepers watching this
video anyway I want to build an elevator
I think I know how to do it I just need
to do it and I will do it now thank you
that just will be pretty simple and
hopefully will work we'll see okay so
here we go there it is it if they should
do work you just play okay so I could
probably put the button closer
okay did not work correctly Hey look at
that nice alright pretty cool the way it
works it's very simple this block pushes
up that activates the observer the
observer activates this block which
pushes this up rinse and repeat there's
probably like a million ways to do it
better but look at that all right so
let's just cover this up and we have a
fully working elevator okay so we have
one secret entrance here which is
obviously impossible to see and then we
have the elevator going right you know
and we're up look at that and then we
can make enchantment oh and I can jump
down for me actually oh nice look at
this
we went from burnt down house to epic
house of epic yeah where all the
chickens make more babies
beigey what do you have to say about
this okay all right cool oh they're all
in here ante oh my god come out little
children come out yes yes you're free
now you're free suffer eternally gosh I
wish you had machine guns cause like you
know terraria has oh my god it's so loud
she said it's so loud oh no I have to
stop this I will have to build the gun
in Minecraft after row maybe that's what
I need to do to defend myself against
evil right I need to set up some sort of
defense so Outsider can't enter alright
let's build a gun in Minecraft oh I will
use cube hamster schematics on this I'm
not taking credit it is a really cool
way of building a a gun so the way this
works it's kind of confusing because
this will update this piston
by having something next to it and
that's the general gist of it because it
I think it moves quicker likewise if you
put this here thanks
so if that piston activates it will
activate this piston and we push this
and we'll have the same principle here
as here this whole series is just become
me building redstone I don't care okay
now we just need to connect this it
should work it should do Merrick oh god
it's scary
maybe I should test oh hey honey
okay I think it works now just need to
put that there and oh no oh no okay
alright back to building it that sucks I
have to okay all right I think the
forward the forward shot should work so
there you go look at that
yeah maybe I should only do make it
forward shooting why is this so
satisfying oh no oh no abandon ship
abandon ship abandon all right so you
can't shoot infinitely fast noted okay
all right we know I'll just damn it why
does the upward not work I think I can
use it to launch myself as well it
should work now oh god let's try it yeah
it work
nice yes
we now have artillery to strike
[Music]
and then one come near us you will pay
consequence it's so satisfying
oh shoot backwards so okay note to self
alright let's line up the chickens now
with the chickens but I don't want Inger
to run free oh my god you idiot come
here yes follow me child no one likes
you environ no one can I yeah I can let
him go they're free we must not let
Inger escape or is he Oh God Code Red
Code Red Code Red a repeat Inger is
escape ship
don't worry chickens you're safe with me
follow me anger will hurt you no more oh
my god they're so awesome when they
follow me so cute
I mean Code Red Code Red
Oh God he's so evil I bet he's plotting
something already I'll see I don't even
know where he is
come come come come that's right I'll
take you to a new line no more evil no
more pain
okay chickens you're safe down there
don't worry I'm gonna do it and
nothing's gonna stop me what what's that
villager you're one of the survivors
from the ac-130 attack
[Music]
let their children nice when has gone
too far
[Music]
instead of killing we should love each
other I don't think so I don't think
school god watch them suffer villager
watch them suffer you will start what if
she was even but look at you now
you become a killing I become a killer
[Music]
what has happened to me
it was Council of what the sheep they
corrupted my mind Oh counselor Watership
is it true it's a true you corrupted my
mind no ok then environs free stop it
get away from me you're the cause of all
of this stop judging me my Oh God no
[Applause]
God's men spend run spend
[Music]
now you are entering a new era where you
shall craft the
the hour of our spells and poop grades
is coming
marzia Edgar and buttons need you
the timer you will face but crawlers is
all about when you are seated on the
porcelain throne Bertie is the game to
play I'm not supposed to have my opinion
about that but the prizes